question très simple ornans doubs qu'il
est ce que vous ne croyez pas que cette
guerre va faire exploser le terrorisme
loin de ça c'est à dire que l'argument
qui est utilisé c'est dire pour
l'instant on n'a aucune preuve contre
l'irak donc on peut rien faire quand on
a trop de preuves qu'elles la corée du
nord avec des armes atomiques on peut
rien faire c'est trop tard alors avant
n'a pas de preuve c'est trop tôt et
après c'est trop tard ce qui se passe en
irak ce qui est en train de se passer en
irak c'est effectivement il a des armes
de destruction massive et j'espère qu'il
ne va pas les utiliser contre les ans
les troupes anglo american ça représente
un danger pour son peuple il l'a prouvé
en 88 en les gazant ça représente un
danger pour les voisins il a prouvé par
deux fois contre l'iran et le koweit et
ça représente un danger pour la
communauté internationale or moi je vous
demande ça va faire exploser le
terrorisme non ça va pas faire exploser
le terroriste et essayer d'empêcher
d'empêcher que à terme ça devienne le
collègue de ben laden pensait pas que
tous les musulmans du monde vont se
sentir solidaire de saddam hussein mais
bien sûr que non de demander mais enfin
et il suffit de poser la question et ne
pas parler comme vous à la place des
irakiens prenez ce que disent les
irakiens salam qui est un cinéaste comme
moi qui a été torturé sous saddam
hussein il est en france il dit la
principale arme de destruction massive
en ce moment c'est saddam hussein mais
non bien sûr c'est pas bush
quand on parle d'armes de destruction
massive si on veut parler de cela il
faut parler des états unis d'abord ce
sont les états unis qui possède le plus
grand nombre d'armes de destruction
massive plus que n'importe qui au
lendemain ils dépensent des milliards
des centaines de milliards par an pour
accroître leur arsenal d'armes de
destruction massive et ce sont justement
les américains qui fournissent le monde
entier avec ses armes de destruction
massive les etats unis ont utilisé deux
fois la bombe atomique et la deuxième
fois a été particulièrement cruelle
parce que les japonais étaient prêts à
se rendre alors qui faut-il des armées
saddam hussein ne trouve pas d'armes
chez lui s'il ya un pays qui doit être
désarmée c'est les états unis qui doit
être désarmée maintenant
n'applaudissez pas quelqu'un qui est en
train de prendre quelqu'un qui est en
train de défendre un assassin il en
train de vous expliquer mais le
dépensent ils en train de dire qu'il
emmènerait câble il est en train de
défendre la sacem son peuple il est en
train de parler à la place des irakiens
et irakiennes il est en train de dire
que saddam n'a pas d'armes de
destruction massive mais même les
inspecteurs les inspecteurs l'ont prouvé
les inspecteurs l'ont montré et les
inspecteurs veulent des preuves écoutez
maintenant de faire rentrer quelqu'un
qui est irakienne voici kenza
kenza bonsoir donc on vous a connu au
départ comme kenza du loft on savait pas
que vous étiez irakienne votre vrai nom
semanal braga est pas du tout kenza vous
êtes né en irak à bagdad le 13 novembre
1976 et saddam hussein arrive au pouvoir
quand vous avez trois ans alors vous
dites quand vous parlez de saddam
hussein oui c'est vrai c'est un tyran
mais sous son règne il ya eu quand même
des avancées technologiques et
industrielles 1 oui c'est vraiment j'ai
vécu la guerre iran irak qui a duré bien
sûr 8 ans tout le monde le sait et c'est
vrai que moi j'ai vu l'irak fleurir dans
les années 80 je crois que ça a été les
années les plus belles que l'irak a vécu
et c'est vrai que j'ai vu des attentes
des avancées technologiques assez
importante depuis que saddam et au règne
mais il n'y a pas eu que ça il a aussi
mis en avant l'éducation qui était
quelque chose de très important dans le
pays et il a fait aussi malgré le fait
qu'il soit un dictateur certes je le
confirme mais il a fait des choses
formidables aussi pour son pays alors
comme staline vous avez 14 ans dans la
guerre du golfe éclate et et dans la
nuit du 17 janvier 1991 vous dormez dans
un sommeil profond votre cartable et
préparer pour aller
matin de guerre et en pleine nuit votre
mère vous traîne dans la cave et j'ai vu
mon père pour la première fois devenir
blanc et devenir non pas un homme formé
un homme qui avait peur et qui savait
pas réellement quoi faire donc ça avec
ma mère a pris les devants et était ce
jour là beaucoup plus forte que mon père
et c'est vrai que ce côté où je voyais
mon père depuis très longtemps cet homme
orientale qui nous montrait toujours
qu'il était disponible qui était le seul
homme le fun l'homme le plus fort de la
famille c'est vrai que ce cet homme
s'est transformé en quelques secondes en
un petit enfant qui avait éclairé moteur
de la guerre alors c'est une nuit qui
vous a extrêmement marqué vous dites
aujourd'hui le premier mercredi du mois
à midi quand j'entends les sirènes à à
paris j'ai les nerfs encore à fleur de
peau vous êtes resté une semaine sans
sortir de l'abri antiatomique que les
japonais avaient construit dans votre
immeuble moderne actuellement weeds dans
ces abris tout le monde était entassé
les gosses il y avait des vieux lille
c'était assez difficile mais c'est le
sort qui avait aucun aucune comment vous
dire on en a pas on n'a rien préparé n'y
avait pas d'eau potable aucune condition
d'hygiène confortable avec les enfants
commençaient à tomber malade moi j'ai vu
des des hommes âgés tomber rapidement
malade il est si mon père est tombé très
malade malgré qu'ils soient médecins et
que je l' ai rarement vu tomber malade
comme cette fois moi je commençais si je
peux me permettre d'utiliser ce terme
j'avais une diarrhée qui commençait un
peu à être assez suspicieuse donc ma
mère une semaine après à lui à dire mon
père écoute moi je pars je joue mais là
le point sur la table le régime j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] moi je la vis de mes
enfants
coûte il n'y a pas de prix pour la vie
de mes enfants donc je me casse avec les
enfants il traversera les frontières
c'est ce qu'elle a fait d'ailleurs vous
êtes parti vous êtes retrouvé dans un
camp de l'onu à la frontière iranienne
vous arriver en france tout ça vous le
racontez dans un bouquin qui va sortir
dans quelques jours vous reviendrai nous
parler du livre mais je tenais ce soir
avoir votre témoignage parce que
finalement c'est votre ville natale
qu'on était en train de bombarder je
pense que je sais pas je pense que
personne ne contredira ici pour dire que
ce n est un dictateur mais j'ai
finalement je suis irakienne enfin je
suis française depuis mes 18 ans mais je
confirme que c'est un dictateur bien sûr
malheureusement pas le droit mais ça
donne on a donné toutes les possibilités
en 80 ans quand il a démarré la guerre
en 90 on lui a donné toutes les
possibilités sur une négociation il a
attaqué le koweit pour là ça fait 12 ans
qu'on lui dit si tu donnes l'épreuve
depuis le 21 avril 91 que tu as tout
désarmés on lève lombard minérale il ya
95%
avec ses parents quatre spots ritter
romain vous savez bien scott ritter qui
a été un inspecteur de l'onu a vraiment
ils étaient en irak pendant s'est fait
virer ainsi 6 et s'est fait virer il a
oublié simplement dire ici à ses tables
en 98 il s'est fait virer et que de 98
maintenant qu est-ce qu apple saddam
hussein qu'est ce qui vous l'avouerez on
sait qu'on a abordé toutes les solutions
en tout cas possibles et imaginables
revenir à tous sera proposé tout et
qu'est ce qu'il a trouvé comme royan 98
de renvoyer les inspecteurs dont scott
ritter donc en 98 il se met hors la loi
1598 bien sûr cela ne soyez pas bushisme
élevé c'est la réponse déjà par
galanterie 1
tous les moyens d'endiguer cette guerre
je suis pour la guerre contre saddam et
pour la paix pour le peuple iranien vous
pensez qu'il n'existe pas d'autre moyen
de 2 2 me les a tous essayé on a tout
essayé les avancées technologiques et
avec tous les renseignements généraux
que bush annonce a en sa possession il
n'a pas pu depuis pas mal de temps en
tout cas depuis très longtemps
débarrassé le l'irak de saddam proposez
quoi mais je propose quoi c'est pas à
moi de donner une solution messieurs je
suis désolé moi je suis chez moi je suis
branché assassine saddam hussein c'est
ça non mais bon je sais pas du tout en
train d assassinat saddam hussein est en
train d'assassiner dure pas longtemps
essayé
marre de mon service et que vous
souhaitez
est-ce que vous en connaissez beaucoup
vous des bombardements sans vie n'ont
qu'à nous avons encore la famille là bas
bien sûr j'ai encore de la famille j'ai
eu récemment quelqu'un de la famille ya
à peu près deux semaines ouais mais on a
eu j'ai ressenti beaucoup de tristesse
dans la voix beaucoup de fatigue je
crois qu'ils ont vraiment vivait
tranquille au téléphone oui j'ai eu un
enclos télé vous attendez en français ce
jour là et pas en irak oui parce qu'en
fait il m'a demandé tout de suite mon
numéro de portable
il y a il m'a appelé d'une cabine
téléphonique qui m'a dit écoute je te
rappelle pourquoi pas pourquoi je vais
vous le dire parce qu'en fait il m'a
quand il m'a appelé j'ai commencé un
petit peu lui poser des questions sur la
situation du pays comment est ce qui se
préparait à la guerre et les quelques
mots de français qu'il a pu utiliser son
parle pas par le pas voilà c'est en fait
je crois qu'il ya un mélange de paranoïa
est un mélange de peur je crois que ils
ont l'impression que la plus simple
cabine téléphonique dans la rue mais
sous écoute donc vous vous avez joué
dans ces dames husser sur effectivement
vous n'êtes pas pour saddam hussein mais
vous trouvé dommage je suis démoralisé
de sophie lombarde et l'irak non lui je
suis très bien à un moment faut agir
c'est ça que j'aimais
temps à perdre avec rasé une mouche avec
un pavé en mai récemment bush a déclaré
qu'il n'avait aucun intérêt à attaquer
l'irak alors vous pouvez m'expliquer
alors qu'elle est au alors lancé son
centre et intérêts si si on vous
explique si on écoute monsieur ou si on
explique ce que dit ou ce qu'on nous
explique dans les journaux ça serait les
intérêts pétroliers si c'est les
intérêts pétroliers il a tout intérêt à
lever l'embargo à faire la paix avec ce
dictateur et à faire immédiatement du
commerce il a tout intérêt c'est son
intérêt immédiat là ils essaient ils ont
essayé depuis le 12 septembre à l'oeil
nu de convaincre l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale que c'était un
danger pour tout le monde ils n'ont pas
réussi parce que les français ont dit
quel que soit le vote nous mettrons
ravel et on pensait qu'ils ont dit aussi
les russes des chinois ah bah oui mais
merci de l'association russe assassins
de tchétchènes leguillon un pied dans le
sang et les chinois c'est yen à men etc
le tibet donc on ses amis avaient pour
se débarrasser d'un adolf hitler on sait
bien allier avec staline qui était pas
non plus un enfant de deux ans on est un
enfant de choeur tout à fait c'est à
dire que c'est là qu'on peut s'allier
avec le diable un certain moment oui
mais quand contre qui là on salit pas
contre saddam la hausse à nier on salit
contre bush et contre les empires gens
qui veulent diriger le monde mais non
mais on peut hein mais qu'est-ce que
vous
dirigez j'ai commencé à diriger le monde
à aucun moment le monde oui d'accord
mais c'est pas ça je pense du tout et
c'est contre tout ancien
une chose très importante qu'il faut
bien comprendre ici
toute la doctrine de bourges correctives
c'est en fait la troisième guerre
mondiale parce que au terme de sept
films sortent toute nation qui est perçu
comme étant
relancer la guerre ce qui veut dire que
l'inde peut attaquer la crise tant le
pakistan peut attaquer note la corée du
sud la corée du nord et vice versa la
terre la chine peut attaquer thaïlande
israël péter knapp est un testing
légitime demande alors où s'arrêtera
donc pour le prix de sa c'est à dire
c'est la paix à tout prix la paix à tout
prix c'est continuer la dictature de
saddam j'ai bien compris ce qui a été
dit et je suis absolument pas d'accord
je suis à segonzac en janvier qu'elle a
ajouté une chose qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette manière de cette manière
de que bush entreprend de vouloir
pacifier en fait donc la région vous
pensez pas que ça ressemble plus à une
colonisation et que demain il va
s'attaquer aussi à la jordanie et va
s'attaquer aussi à l'arabie saoudite
il va s'attaquer aussi aux autres pays
qui l'entourent vous avez l'impression
que c'est une joueuse aussi une méthode
pour pour coloniser lorient et pour
monopoliser lorient que je ne sais pas
ça écoutez on a l'expérience arrêté me
prendre des hypothèses prônée par le
kosovo au kosovo est ce qu'ils sont
restés qu'ils ont occupée non ils ont
donné le mandat à la communauté
internationale pour que monsieur
kouchner essaye de remettre des éléments
de démocratie est ce que quand ils ont
fait la guerre en 91 ils sont restés au
koweit et ils ont essayé de développer
leur empire au koweit on leur reproche
suffisamment ils n'ont même pas donner
des éléments pour essayer de faire
avancer la démocratie c'est est ce que
est ce que pour les autres que va
devenir l'irak après basse que ba doit
d'y aller aujourd'hui on n'a aucune
réponse rapport à l'allemagne à layrac
je vais vous le dire vous le savez
qu'ici d'irak et démocratique comme il
ya 60% de chiites l'irak va être un pays
chiite qui va donc être intégré à chaque
c'est la magie dans l'air comme l'iran
parce que ce qu'on connaît des
discussions qui ont lieu à londres qui a
eu lieu à washington avaient tous les
exilés ils sont 4 millions comme vous il
ya 4 millions de personnes qui ont fui
le pays et des démocrates et ils
essayent de construire un autre pays
possible ça soit possible de discuter
qu'un de bien sûr qu'elle sera
directement avec un bang avec les
américains et la communauté
internationale c'est vrai que les
anglais les hautes vagues avec le dire
merci aux américains c'est ça a plaidé
sur comme je leur dis merci pour avoir
libéré en effet non content d 2
700 et hitler vous c'est ça ab je crois
que c'est c'est pire parce que nucléaire
a déjà existé alors que saddam hussein
ces cinquante ans après claire de
tolérer et qu'on supporte ce qui s'est
passé ce qui est en train de se passer
par rapport au peuple irakien est une
abomination vu le souvenir chemin de la
période des chevaliers juste avec ça je
vais vous dire une chose je crois que si
aujourd'hui vous demandez aux irakiens
s'il préfère demain à voir les
américains sur leur sol où vivre encore
20 30 40 ans avec sa dame qui est un
dictateur je peux vous assuré je peux
vous assurer qu'il vivra encore avec sa
dalle a simplement ajouté d'autres
atouts plus beaux atouts classe b le
dernier cervélo renaud girard le figaro
regardez ce qu'ils disent les légendes
de bagdad
quand on lui demande s'il n'a pas peur
il répond avec un grand sourire il y a
une semaine je ne vous aurais jamais
parlé comme ça mais depuis hier j'ai
senti que la peur mais avaient
soudainement quitté je me sens comme
libéré d'un immense fardeau enfin
pouvoir dire ce qu'on veut dans leur
immense majorité les irakiens veulent un
changement de régime ils souhaitent que
leur pays soit placé sous la protection
des américains et des anglais ils
haïssent la position de la france de
l'allemagne et de la russie bush le père
à libérer le koweït bouche le fils va
libérer l'irak la rue rachid la plus
vieille de bagdad devra un jour porté
son nom et ça continue tous les gens
alors qu'en penses-tu c'est pour quand
on en a assez d'attendre et celui-là
saddam hussein en tentant population
tout le monde d'accord si on prend parmi
la population qu'elle garde et c'est pas
du tout c'est pas du celluloïd garou et
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ce
journaliste est tout à fait honnête par
tous les consultants qu'il pouvait être
simplement il ya une semaine personne
lui parlait maintenant tout le monde va
lui parler en lui disant mais pourvu
qu'ils arrivent vite et qui nous libère
de 30 ans de dictature mais on n'a
jamais demandé aux américains de venir
nous libérer de quoi que ce soit je
campe les irakiens
excusez nous restons calmes au delà
merci roma joue peu merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu